7 novembre en voir les chroniques de la
haine ordinaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était temps que janvier fit place à
février
janvier est de très loin le mois le plus
saumâtre le plus grand bleu le moins
pétillant de l'année
les plus sous doués d'entre vous chers
auditeurs auront remarqué que janvier
débute le premier
je veux dire que c'est pas moi qui ai
commencé
et qu'est ce que le 1er janvier sinon le
jour au nid entre tous ou des brassées
d'imbéciles joviaux se jette sur leur
téléphone pour vous rappeler
l'inexorable progression de votre compte
à rebours avant le départ vers le père
lachaise
dieu merci il n'y a pas de quoi mais si
mais si cet hiver afin de m'épargner au
maximum les assauts grotesque de ses
enthousiasmes et hypocrite j'ai modifié
légèrement le message de mon répondeur
téléphonique
au lieu de deux bonjour à tous j'ai mis
bonne année mon cul
c'est net c'est sobre et ça vole
suffisamment bas pour que les grossiers
trouve ça vulgaire
plus encore que les quarante cinq
précédents mois de janvier que j'ai eu
le malheur de traversée par la faute de
ma mère
celui ci est à marquer d'une pierre
noire je n'en retiendrai pour ma part
que les glauque et morne soubresauts de
l'actualité dont il fut parsemé rappelez
vous c'est un avocat trop murs qui
tombent sa veuve qui descend de son
petit cheval pour monter sur ses grands
chevaux
la concierge est dans l'escalier madame
villemin est dans l'impasse
tandis que de biture en biture les
graphologues de la sphère qui ne des
soul plus
continue à jouer à pincemi et grégory
sont dans un bateau
côté bouillon de culture francis huster
attrape le cid
avec jean marais
au progrès de lyon le spécialiste des
chiens écrasés et le responsable des
chats noyer
apprenant carsan rachète le journal se
domine pour ne pas faire grève
le 15 premier coup dur
balavoine est mort
le 16 deuxième coup dur
sabatier est toujours vivant
l'espagne fallait-il qu'elle fût myope
reconnaît israël
le 19 on croit apercevoir mère teresa
chez régine c'était bardos ou à monter
votre
le 23 il fait 9 degrés à massy palaiseau
on n'avait pas vu ça à 23 janvier depuis
1936 et je pose la question qu'est ce
que ça peut [ __ ]
le 26 sur tf1 le roi des [ __ ]
dégouline de charité chrétienne dans une
entreprise de restauration cardiaque
pour nouveaux pauvres
heureusement j'ai mon alka seltzer
le 27 l'un des trois légionnaires
assassins du paris vintimille et c'est
timidement de se suicider dans sa
cellule
ses jours ne sont pas en danger
je n'en dirais pas autant de ses nuits
le 29 feu d'artifice tragique à cap
kennedy bilan 380 tonnes d'hydrogène et
d'oxygène liquide béton langage
et le soir du 31
comme tous les autres soirs joëlle
kauffmann embrasse ses deux garçons et
elle rentre dans sa chambre elle est
tout seul
tu ne dors pas très bien
enfin voici février sec comme un coup de
trique et glacée comme un mort avec son
mardi gras qui nous courent sur la crêpe
c'est le mois de la saint blaise qui rit
dans son ascèse et de sainte véronique
qui pleurent dans les tuniques
c'est aussi le temps du carême où les
maigres chrétiens d'ethiopie peuvent
enfin je n'ai la tête haute dans la
salle noire de dieu
les statistiques sont irréfutables c'est
en février que les hommes s'entretuent
le moins dans le monde - de tueries
guerrière moindre x crapuleuses moins
d'agressions nocturnes dans les rues
sombres du xviiie arrondissement de
paris où la sécurité est elle
habituellement que les arabes n'ose même
plus sortir tout seul le soir
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au nombre des cambriolages qui
diminue de 6 % en février et tout ça
pour quoi et bien après les enquêtes
scientifiques les plus poussées les
sociologues sont parvenus à cette
incroyable conclusion si les hommes font
moins de conneries en février c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont que 28 jours
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
attention attention y'a pas que les
nouveaux pauvres il ya aussi les
nouveaux riches
pour venir en aide à mes amis nouveaux
riches qui crèvent dans leur cholestérol
en plein hiver à méribel
j'ai décidé d'ouvrir les restaurants du
foie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
envoyez-moi des tonnes de verveine et
des quintaux de biscottes s'appelle le
bon dieu voulait rendre à
sans vouloir offenser les marchands de
confiture il faut bien se rendre à
l'évidence les sirupeux commence à nous
les englué
depuis des lustres déjà la mièvrerie
d'un humanisme sanglotant enrobé l'homo
sapiens occidentale infiltrant en son
coeur débordant de remords colonialiste
le flou sucre et de la plus vulgaire
sensiblerie mais bon on se contentait de
patauger dans le fil andreu 106 noyé
trois sous pour l'abbé pierre une
marraine pour le vietnam une cuillère et
pour mamadou et on pouvait retourner
finir son foie gras la conscience
débarbouiller et larmes dans les
pantoufles
mais voici qu'une horde électronique de
rockers anglophone sur gazeille screens
se prend soudain d'émotion au récit
pitoyable de la misère éthiopienne dans
les navrantes images nous prouve en tout
cas qu'on peut garder la ligne loin de
contrexéville
[Applaudissements]
gravé sur le vinyle les miaulements
effrayant et les bras m'en mêler de ces
chanteurs transit défaire d'un jour sur
les ondes et c'est le monde entier qui
glougloute dans la mélasse la larme en
crue et la honte sous le bras
pantelant d'admiration pour tout ce qui
vient d'amérique les troubadours fin de
siècle du rock auvergnats veulent faire
exactement la même chose ils
s'agglutinent en vain aux portes des
maquignons du 33 tours renault a eu
l'idée avant alors chante avec lui
à la vue du clip c'est dur en cuir pis
autant leur douleur sur leur leggins
margot dégoulinante de chagrin
panafricain se prive des mémoires de
patrick sabatier pour pouvoir s'acheter
le disque
mais voici l'hiver venu les nouveaux
comptes eut la dinde les nouvelles d'un
des yvelines les nouveaux pauvres ont
faim les charitables épisodique entre
deux bords frais de confit d'oie vont
pouvoir épancher leur élan diabétiques
le plus célèbre des employés de paul
lederman ouvre les restaurants du coeur
des tripiers d'où des épiciers ému de
tendre charcutier le coeur bouffis de
charité chrétienne et de cholestérol
montrent leur bonté à tous les passants
sur les trois chaînes
margot revend son disque pour l'ethiopie
pour acheter des pieds de porc ou beurs
islamique
[Musique]
tel un enfant sud-américain s'enfonçant
dans la boue la france entière font
doucement dans le miel des orioles de
saintdo pouce au front des nouveaux
bigot du showbiz sa tartuffe à tour
d'antenne sur tf1
dans la foulée un chanteur sans père se
donne aux orphelins c'est son famille
sur antenne 2 un animateur lacrymal
chante la complainte à nodules des
damnés du cancer c'est saint vincent sur
fr3 un foutu d'aboutir les pontifes
d'esculape tendent la sébile au
carrefour sos métastases médecin sans
scanner ou vrai moi cette porte où je
frappe en pleurant partout les à l'armée
du salut nous poisse de leurs éruptions
hyperglycémique
heureusement dieu mais cartel si
possible sous anesthésie générale
il reste encore en france et pas
seulement en france en colombie en
ethiopie même des êtres humains qui
n'ont rien perdu de leur dignité des
êtres qu un sort heureux a mis à l'abri
de la pitié des hommes eux n'ont pas à
mendier en casquette à galons dorés il
somnole dans les tourelles antiseptique
de leurs charges astiquez il suce des
caramels en attendant le déclenchement
de la troisième
quand on lèvera des impôts pour les
mourants du monde et qu'on fera la quête
pour préparer les guerres j'irai chanter
avec renault en attendant oui mon pote g
s'emballe et je les garde
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Musique]
5ème 6ème bientôt septième chaîne
rassurez vous il y en aura pas 8 il n'y
a pas assez de frères seydoux
en tout cas la pluri télévision- it est
inéluctable alors calmos et comme disait
attila à sainte geneviève prenons un peu
de recul sinon comment veux-tu
passé le premier moment de saintes
fureur et la première réaction salutaire
de rejet posons-nous paisiblement la
question cette cinquième chaîne qui nous
pend à l'antenne sera t-elle vraiment ce
dépotoir haï débat ce que nous redoutons
temps où des brutes italo wisigothe soit
fait de lire vont venir jusque dans nos
bras pour charcuter nos bobine est
décimée nos pellicule sous un torrent de
réclames signer phobique
sans vouloir me faire le chantre des
lessiviers et encore moins la coloc
démarche en dessous j'ai jamais pu finir
la mienne il m'apparaît à la réflexion
que ce projet de cinquième chaîne ne
manque pas d'un certain charme
d'abord ça va faire chier les cinéphiles
et quiconque est susceptible de faire du
mal un cinéphile ne saurait être tout à
fait mauvais dirait leur idole le
méchant monsieur fils qui sont ils les
cinéphiles sinon ces poussières aux
ectoplasmes de la culture dans le noir
qui glisse gonflé de suffisance au
dessus du populaire sur le nuage opaque
de leurs ésotérisme leur cerveau
presbytes recroquevillé dans la
naphtaline ne les autorise à comprendre
que par le petit bout de leur
entendement réactionnaire ça ne cesse
bouddhique sur l'abscons ça ne réalise
qu'un retardement quand de funès est
mort qu'il avait le génie de jerry lewis
ça fait semblant de cause et anglais et
d'après mon beau frère qui fait dans les
tubes à l'institut pasteur s'est pourvue
de quéquette trop petit pour attraper le
sida sens at-elle
[Musique]
on va nous entrecouper les films de
spots publicitaires et alors
comme dirait le pen soyons clairs
il y a deux sortes de films les bons et
les mauvais d'accord non le problème
avec les bons avec les bons films à la
télévision c'est qu'on est vissé dans
son fauteuil sans aucune possibilité
d'échappatoire de crainte d'en manquer
la moindre image désormais grâce à la
pub on va pouvoir se lever pour un pipi
salubre pour aller chercher les
pistaches dans la cuisine ou pour finir
le char à la hache
quant aux mauvais film plus on les
charcute plus ont fait oeuvre utile non
quelle fourbe qu'elle sournois qu'elle
demeurait quel cinéphile oserait
soutenir le contraire il faut également
savoir que la cinquième chaîne en
dépoussiérant les trains trains va faire
souffrir les trois premières pour
l'heure des hordes avachi de fossiles
comateux collabore à la prospérité de la
ringardise syndicaux administrative dans
nos trois chaînes d'état
dans la torpeur immuable de leur
incompétence ronds de cuir c'est
cachalots échoués barbotte re plaide
médiocrité dans la boue tiède de leur
inefficacité
la seule pensée de voir passer une idée
neuve les plongent sous leur bureau
certes le pétomane et chantal goya ne
s'en plaint guère
mais d'autres et j'en connais qui
crèvent de faim dans leur sous pente
avec leur chien maigre et leur talent
censuré ne manqueront pas de se réjouir
saintement de la mise à la retraite
anticipée de ces potentats mou
au fait j'ai croisé l'autre soir dans un
restaurant le fameux italien moody et il
allait le front haut cerné de pépiant de
groupies qui chassait l'autographe je
dois dire qu'ils aient trouvé plutôt
sympa berlusconi et c'est berlusconi
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
ça s'appelle un clip parce que c'est
bref je dirais plutôt un film parce que
ça dit une histoire ça apporte une idée
dans la cour d'un lycée un grand
adolescent comme un tournant autour
d'une gamine on le devine encore
boutonneux elle toujours chrysalide avec
dans les yeux c'était moi brûlant
qu'elles ont à l'âge des seins qui
poussent un petit garçon je lis les
regarde intrigué peut être inquiet
legrand doucement enveloppe la petite de
son bras rassurants
il la pousse ainsi jusqu'aux toilettes
ne passait pas sur france musique c'est
pas qu'aux gens
il la pousse jusqu'aux toilettes et là
il extrait de sa poche un petit sachet
blanc et le pose sur le rebord du lavabo
david j'aime penser que le petit
s'appelle david tout philosémitisme mise
à part
david donc s'interpose entre la nymphe
et l'acné 1 s'empare du sachet blanc et
le jette dans la lunette du cabinet il
tire la chasse d'eau apparaît alors
bouffantes ou l'écran en lettres d'or ce
cri du coeur la drogue c'est de la merde
ce petit film il existe ce petit film
qu'on verra dans les salles de cinéma
dans quelques jours et à la télévision
si les programmateurs s'éveille à
l'intelligence on peut rêver
a été écrit et réalisé par jean marie
périer en collaboration étroite et avec
le chaleureux soutien de jacques séguéla
séguéla dont le quotient intellectuel
dépasse largement le chiffre de la
température anale dès qu'ils cessent de
nous comparer le message publicitaire à
l'expression onirique de quelques néo
romantisme été ré
le film de périers séguéla dure une
minute c'est un chef-d'oeuvre ça existe
un chef-d'oeuvre de 60 secondes
personnellement je changerai pas viens
poupoule contre deux barils de la
traviata
ni ce film plume 6 contre 2 quintaux de
lelouch
c'est beau et terriblement efficace je
les montre et à une petite fille qui
m'est familière et qui a presque l'âge
de celle du film et j'ai lu dans ses
yeux furtif et flamboyant le dégoût
salutaire des immondices et exotiques et
pourtant dieu mais masculin si possible
au laser ça fait moins mal
il s'est trouvé de consternante badernes
pour hurler au scandale ces censeurs que
seule la crainte du pléonasme m'interdit
de qualifié d'imbécile se sont montrés
choqués par la dureté du film engoncée
dans le carcan étriqué de leurs
certitudes apprises ils sont de ceux qui
hurle à la lune morte les cris de leurs
coeurs surgelés on ne doit pas dire de
gros mots même pour lutter contre la
drogue on ne doit pas mettre ses doigts
dans son nez quand on monte à l'assaut
on ne doit pas mettre ses coudes sur la
chaise électrique
les mêmes se justifie en arguant que ce
type de propagande attire les jeunes
vers la drogue au lieu de les en
dégoûter ils disent aussi que les manifs
anti raciste exacerbe les désirs de
pogroms des eunuques en cuir et alors
quoi
chut silence pas un mot après tout
c'était le bon temps celui où leurs
bonnes enceintes de leurs soubresauts
obscène alès défoncé sans bruit les
entrailles à l'aiguillé à tricoter avant
d'aller crever au caniveau comme un
junkie isuzu vers doses je connais bien
ce type d'argument récemment à la fin
d'un spectacle dans une ville de
province j'ai reçu dans ma loge un
journaliste d'une radio libre vous savez
à de ces zombies mou qui s'imaginent
qu'il suffit de flatuler dans un walkman
pour faire de la radiophonie
en essayant de brancher son philips à
deux têtes sur un magnétophone henry de
ce mammifère mme dit qu'il avait aimé
l'essentiel de mon spectacle ce qui me
rend bruni d'emblée
et puis il ajouta je vous assure je cite
sans fioritures
mais que mon cas ça se fait que dans vos
sketchs vous rigolez sur les cancéreux
et d'ajouter devant mme amina vrai en
tout cas vous critiquez le cancer
il ya des métastases qui se perd non
[Musique]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique se
mettre vraiment qui passent l'hiver
l'ex-salle légaux qui est grise
insidieuse et sournoise
d'autant plus meurtrière qu'elle est
impalpable on ne peut pas l'étrangler
elle glisse entre les doigts comme la
muqueuse immonde autour de l'anguille
morte
elle sent elle pue elle souille
c'est la rumeur
répondez moi franchement est ce que oui
ou non j'ai l'air contagieux
pardon
je vous pose la question parce que le
bruit court que j'ai le sida
ça m'est revenu de la bouche d'un [ __ ]
le bruit par le sida
sa mère venue de la bouche d'un [ __ ] qui
le tenait d'un autre [ __ ] le sida par le
bruit ce garçon le [ __ ] de la bouche du
calme est revenu le bruit m'a dit que
l'autre garçon le [ __ ] qui veut refiler le
sida au [ __ ] par lequel mes revenus le
bruit lui avait dit que rika zaraï
qui actuellement avec le pen
mais ne le répétez pas
donc il y avait 10 et que rika zaraï
racontait partout que j'avais le sida
c'est dégueulasse non
c'est dégoûtant dieu m'embrasse si
possible pas sur la bouche on sait
jamais
et bien c'est ça la rumeur la rumeur
c'est c'est le glaive merdeuse soulier
de germes épidémique que brandissent
dans l'ombre les impuissants honteux
elle se profile à peine à sortir des
égouts pour vomir ses miasmes poisseux
ou brouillards crépusculaire d hiver
branche it e elle nous dit rappelez vous
que les pompidou sont d'inquiétant
paillard que la chanteuse sheila n'est
pas une femme que simone signoret n'est
pas capable d'écrire ses livres tout
seul
plus menteuses que la rumeur tumeur
mais elle s'en fout elle a éjaculé son
venin répugnant jusque dans orléans ou
des hyènes anonyme susurrait naguère
sans frémir que les femmes qui entrait
dans certains magasins tenus par les
juifs de la ville disparaissait à tout
jamais vers d'introuvables bordel
orientaux et puis comme le monstre du
loch ness la rumeur fait son rot et
retourne à sarah's
hier matin j'ai bien cru l'avoir relevé
le coin
j'ai entendu un
amuseur dominical notoire à qui par
parenthèse je dois beaucoup j'ai entendu
cet homme suggéré en public que guy
bedos était très méchant qu'il n'avait
aucun talent et tenez vous bien qu'il
perdait ses cheveux
bon je ne fais pas de la radio pour
défendre les gens que j'aime contre les
piqûres de moustiques ils savent très
bien où elle ddt mais qu'on me permette
ici de m'étonner qu'on touche à mon pote
avec une telle désinvolture
car enfin ce n'est un secret pour
personne que guy bedos qui est mon
copain fait rire et réfléchir la france
à guichets fermés depuis 20 ans
s'il n'avait aucun talent ça se saurait
à barbizon
s'il perd ses cheveux je puis témoigner
sous serment que ce n'est jamais dans ma
soupe
et s'il est très méchant
si guy bedos est très méchant je vous
jure que ce n'est pas dans ses yeux mes
enfants qui sont petits vous le diront
vous savez moi aussi si je veux je peux
ébranlé des certitudes et susciter des
suspicions
figurez vous qu'à ce qu'on raconte
schultz appelle le web était tellement
c'est incongru tellement ses bas il
parait
il paraît que jacques martin est un
brave homme
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
le plus sourd d'entre vous chers
auditeurs aura entendu parler des
demoiselles monaco
à moins que vous ne lisiez que des
journaux intelligent vous n'avez pas pu
échapper à leur effigie de laitières peu
de clés qui s'étale périodiquement à la
une des organes populacier savez le
poids des mots le choc des lolos voyez
ce que je veux dire
rien ne m'autorise à porter le moindre
jugement esthétique ou morale sur le
bien fondé des exhibitions répétitif de
ces cocottes d'azur dont les images
rassurantes via une forte à propos nous
faire oublier les femmes squelette au
sein vide accroupis sur les plages de
sable infinie de nos lointains sahel je
ne me permettrais pas davantage de
ricaner prétentieusement d'un lapsus n'a
guère échapper des lèvres aux aubergines
de la cadette c'est l'habitude et
stéphanie
c'était au cours de l'émission scoop à
la une produite par catherine barma le
27 octobre dernier sur tf1 il était 16
heures 40 2 non je donne d'entrée de jeu
c'est fastidieuse précision
bureaucratique à l'intention de l'avocat
des grimaldi spécialisés
qu'il est spécialisé dans les procédures
diffamatoires afin de lui épargner une
action en justice perdue d'avancé
on n'entend pas le bras d'honneur quand
je pose d'un drain ce fait on débattait
donc sur ce plateau des avantages et des
inconvénients de la tauromachie
lorsque mademoiselle monaco c'est fanny
donc eu cette saillie si j'ose dire si
j'ose dire s'agissant de ces fiers
bestiaux dont la haute tenue copulatoire
n'est plus à vanter chez les bobines en
rut
deux points ouvrons donc les guillemets
avec révérence c'est la princesse qui
cause je suis contre la tauromachie
après tout les taureaux ne sont ils pas
des êtres humains comme les autres
je le répète il ne peut s'agir en
l'occurrence que d'un lapsus un lapsus
bien pardonnable et non pas de
l'expression involontaire d'une tendance
à la zoophilie
nous ne devons pas perdre de vue avant
de nous lancer dans de malveillantes
insinuations totalement injustifié que
les produits destinés à faire vendre du
papier comme lotus où les princesses
monégasques sont soumises à toutes
sortes de pressions avant d'être livrée
au public
d'où une certaine fatigue bien excusable
après tout les roitelets d'opérette sont
ils pas des êtres humains comme les
autres
mais alors direz vous et vous n'auriez
pas tort pourquoi cet imbécile nous
bourrer souffle-t-il le cortex avec 6
ragoût méridionaux et bien simplement
parce que j'ai été profondément heurté
dans ma fierté républicaine d'entendre
et de voir l'autre jour un animateur de
jeu français dont je tairai le nom pour
ne pas faire de publicité à patrice
laffont
se payer jusqu'à se lécher les genoux
devant la donzelle susnommé et lui dire
je cite c'est un grand honneur pour nous
de vous avoir parmi nous ce soir votre
altesse sérénissime
alors là je dis non était ce vraiment la
peine de guillotiné le gros cap et de se
battre pour les congés payés de donner
le droit de vote aux épices hier et
maintenant de supporter la gueule à
krasucki tout ça pour en arriver là
allons patrice patrice mon pote secoue
toi on a quand même pas pris la bastille
que pour en faire un opéra
sim républicain
primo ce n'est pas un grand honneur pour
toi patrice que de recevoir stéphanie de
monaco à la finale des chiffres et des
lettres c'est un grand honneur pour elle
que d'avoir le droit de s'exhiber
multimédia alors qu'elle n'a rien
d'autre à faire que de montrer son
blaser son blason à tous les passants
deuxio on n'appelle pas n'importe qui
altesse sérénissime
de la hauteur et de la sérénité il y en
a chez l'abbé pierre chez chez les
basanés qui marche contre les cons grand
teint il y en a chez joëlle kauffmann
cas pas tellement le temps de pleurer il
y en a chez les toubibs aux 80 des
tortures et des morts de la hauteur et
de la sérénité il y en a un chez mère
teresa et même chez le militant transit
qui croient dans l'humanité le dimanche
l'altesse et la sérénité la majesté en
un mot ça n'est pas héréditaire mon
camarade ça ne s'attrape pas au lit
comme la vérole où le droit d'aînesse
la majesté ça vient du coeur des gens
c'est une élégance qu'on achète page
pierre cardin
[Applaudissements]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
ce matin là qui était le matin du
septième jour
dieu ne se sentait pas très bien
il faut dire que les six premiers jours
il n'avait pas ménagé sa peine créant
coup sur coup la lumière la terre les
maires l'homme les animaux le ciel bleu
les étoiles jaunes
enfin tout ce [ __ ] de bordel de dieu
qui nous entoure et sans lequel nous
n'aurions jamais pu connaître l'arthrite
du genou et la bombe à neutrons
et donc le septième jour dieu se sentit
mou et sans fut consultez-le interne de
garde à l'hôtel dieu
comment allez-vous mon dieu sans qu'ils
docteur et dieu dit bref comme un lundi
c'est fin jeudi le docteur on est
dimanche
mais que ressentez-vous précisément mon
dieu est dieu dit c'est difficile à dire
j'ai l'impression d'être creux et sans
contours voyez comme comme qui dirait
ballonné mais sans la baudruche autour
du rien
j'ai l'impression de ne pas être là et
ne pas être ailleurs non plus et pour
être clair docteur je crois que je crois
que je n'existe pas et dans ma situation
vous comprendrez que c'est extrêmement
pénible
rassurez vous ce n'est qu'une sensation
affirme al docteur qui était plus pieux
qu'une cuisse de grenouille intégristes
je vais tout de même vous examinez dites
33 et dieu dit on ne donne pas d'ordre à
dieu quand le prix
excusez moi je vous prie de dire 33000
docteur et dieu 10 33 33 33 bien
maintenant faite à eux je vous prie de
faire à
et dieu dix à
vingt dieux s'exclama le docteur qui
voyait grand
et dieu très inquiète dit et on est
bien mon dieu c'est tout à fait
incroyable vous vous avez la gorge si
sombre que je n'y vois rien et dieu dit
c'est normal les voies du seigneur sont
impénétrables
sais pas ce que je veux dire mais mon
dieu vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez pas
de moi profond et sans son moi profond
l'homme 9,1 sans son moi profond
personne ne peut vivre repris le docteur
tiens quand je vous disais que
j'existais pas c'est pas des conneries
dit dieu
c'est égal on est bien peu de chose
constaté le docteur on est même rien du
tout est dit dieu ni moi ni vous puisque
sans moi sans moi pour vous créez vous
l'avez dans le néant
au nom de dieu dit le docteur je vous en
prie dieu bon il combien vous dois-je
docteur proches c'est pas moins de dix
mois vous voulez des données nous
aujourd'hui notre pain quotidien
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude et
deux baguettes bien cuites pour le
docteur freud des dieux
[Applaudissements]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique cela
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
oubliant toute réserve y compris sa
réserve d'humour qui devrait normalement
le mettre à l'abri des besoins de son
imprésario voilà-t-il pas que le plus
petit de nos imitateur qui est aussi le
plus grand ce qu met soudain à exiger
frénétiquement de figurer dans une
émission de télévision où l'on a
nullement visiblement pas envie de
l'inviter
je rappelle les fêtes à l'intention des
moins futile de mes auditeurs que les
potins indiffère et que le rpt ago las
le plus époustouflant man le plus
époustouflant mans bien qu'ils soient
wallon le sait pas où chercher vers
paris le plus époustouflant mandou et
des lurons s'est récemment pris de bec
chez lipp avec la journaliste anne
sinclair qui fait rien qu'à pas vouloir
le recevoir dans son magazine 7 sur 7
cette attitude de quémandeurs fort
étrange venant d'un gars sont à juste
titre orgueilleux de son image publique
m'amène à trois réflexions que
j'appellerais respectivement la première
la deuxième et la troisième une égard un
certain respect de la hiérarchie qui me
vient d'un grand oncle agricole qui
mettait toujours la charrue après les
boeufs dans le souci bien compréhensible
d'aller de l'avant à travers les champs
vertendre ou le mulot mutins des
culottes aux plats l'amulette hoguet
[Applaudissements]
premières réflexions
quand j'étais petit j'avais une vieille
tante avec des poils au pâté de la
moustache façon gratte-cul sous le grain
violet qui lui tenaient lieu donné une
espèce de folcoche de soupente qui
sentaient moins le chat que le pipi du
sien
et qui ne m'aimais pas seigneur comment
peut-on je suis si charmant
aussi me débattaient âprement chaque
fois que ma mère me traîner vers la
celle saint cloud pour y aller tirer les
rois chez cette gorgone plate dont
jacques borel épiphane et les jour
d'épiphanie
annie l'année fanny
loin de moi l'idée de comparer cette
parenté inopportune à la très belle et
très troublante anne sinclair vos
adorables pied de laquelle je dépose ici
conjointement mon plus beau camélia et
ils l'inaltérable désespoir ou me
recroqueville la penser qu'elle ne sera
jamais mienne qu'au creux des nuits
fantasmatique d'orgies parallèle où mon
émoi sega
met enfin dieu m'en porte mais pas tout
de suite j'ai pas fini mon 4 heures
n'est-il pas étrange qu'un garçon
infiniment célèbre et célébré en son
pays fasse soudain des petits pieds les
petites mains pour être invité à tout
prix chez quelqu'un qu'il n'aime pas qui
ne l'aiment pas non plus et qui n'a
manifestement aucune envie de le voir
deuxième réflexion
quel texte de loi inique
enfin il fait ce qu'il veut
[Rires]
quels textes de lois iniques obligera et
soudain l'animateur d'une émission à
recevoir un clown plutôt qu'un autre ne
croulant nous point sous suffisamment de
règlement poussiéreux et briseur d'élan
pour qu on ne vienne y ajouter de
surcroît un cahier des charges des
gugusses 1 un contrat d'alternance des
pitres une flexibilité de l'emploi chez
relie rigolo un comique troupier de
gauche de lundi un pétomane de droite le
mardi le tout au nom de quelle
objectivité je vous le demande
si c'est la juste répartition des
charges qui fait l'objectivité des
choses je ne donne pas cher de celle de
mes couilles
[Applaudissements]
s'il y avait si jamais il ya des gens de
plus de 10 ans à l'ecoute je leur
signale que coup il se veut dire
testicules
troisième réflexion je le dis en toute
modestie je ne suis pas n'importe qui
m'ont attaché de presse vous le
confirmera aussi je comprends mal le
mépris qu'affiche à mon endroit
messieurs gillot-pétré danaé vincenti
tous responsables de l'animation des
bulletins météorologiques télévisée
vous n'allez pas croire
aucun de ses animateurs ne m'a jamais
invité à son émission
alors que je suis absolument passionnant
tant que cumulonimbus hologue dans l'art
de commenter à 2 les aventures de
l'anticyclone des açores et que je suis
le meilleur pour parler des zones de
basse pression qui délimiteront sur nos
régions un temps variable après
dissipation des brumes matinales
et que je suis absolument irrésistible
quand j'annonçais températures relevées
sous abri ce matin à 4 heures au nord
d'une ligne bordeaux strasbourg et que
si jamais je rencontre madame brigitte
simonetta dans un restaurant du coeur j
foulenay dans son canigou parce que un
tel mépris pour un continental venant
d'une nonne autonomistes récupérer sa
confinent au racisme
ou alors dit tout de suite que je suis
parano
[Applaudissements]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait vraiment qui parce qu'ils
veulent
connaissez-vous rien de plus humiliant
pour une grande personne que d'être
publiquement déculottée par un enfant
non j'entends déculottée au sens figuré
ça va de soi pour ce qui est des
tentatives de détournement de majeur
faites moi confiance je sais me défendre
en revanche j'entends grande personne au
sens propre trois fois hélas je devrais
dire 46 fois hélas mon expulsion
placentaire ayant coïncidé avec le début
d'un exode encore plus générale
je suis même une grande personne envoie
tassement
qui je le sens bien que j'ai dépassé
l'âge mûr l'âge mûr qui finalement n'est
n'est que l'âge qui précède l'oeuf
pourri
si si je commence à m'essouffler dans
les secrétaires même bilingue
et bientôt jacquot stoehr est sur les
rives mortelle du troisième âge celui où
tout bascule où l'on s'éveille un triste
matin sur les genoux avec les mains
froides et le grise aux tempes
la veille encore tout allait bien pour
toi mon frère tant qu'il a les artères
plus molle que le sexe les talons piaf
et puis bon tu sais ce que c'est quand
l'un de ses membres ne lui permet plus
de cavale et on abat le vieux cheval
pouf pouf avant ces digressions de
cimetière où la grisaille givrés de cet
hiver de merde me pousse malgré moi
j'allais vous narrer comment je fus
récemment humilié que dis-je bafoués au
plus profond de ma vanité de mal à poil
dur par un petit garçon un petit suisse
oui petit suisse tous les deux tout
sucre et qui s'appelait hans et qui
avait 8 ans et demi au moment des fêtes
c'est à dire avant-hier
un petit garçon normal avec des cheveux
tendre et des yeux bleus parallèle
je venais de déjeuner avec quelques amis
chez son papa un suisse riches excusez
moi je bafouille
un suisse qui fourni des rations repas
aux compagnies d'aviation dans le monde
entier un type bien ne me faites pas
dire qu'un confédération helvétique je
ne calembours coin dans les alpes
où pousse café en ce qui me tient pour
un être d'exception parce que je dis des
gros mots dans le poste voulu à tout
prix me montrer les la décoration de sa
chambre
c'était sur 12 mètres carrés du sol au
plafond et jusque sous le lit un musée
de l'avion avec tout ce qui vole plane
ou sombres depuis les biplans un certain
façon blériot jusqu'à l'invincible
navette d'artifice que vous savez
en passant par le brigade de pont et le
spirit of san luis du regretté linda
farrow gratter de ma grand-mère de
sauter les chefs du bourget donc moins
de console mans
le petit hans m'expliqua que son père
avait naturellement aider à sa
collection d'aéroplan mais que
maintenant ce qui l'intéressait surtout
lui hand c'était les chasseurs et les
bombardiers
quand nous fûmes revenu au salon je
félicite et le gamin pour le stupéfiant
de précocité de son héros philly
casanière tout en étonnant tout de même
de sa nouvelle attirance vers les
machines de guerre
je m'en fous quand je serai grand je
serai pilote de chasse décréte at il
avec une pointe d'agressivité dans le
ton est alors moi pauvre moralistes de
café tabac
voilà-t-il pas quand porté par un élan
de pacifisme moisi indigne du
responsable du stage raphia longue durée
de la maison de la culture de saint
jérôme deschamps
volatile point qu'au lieu de me taire
exalté hackers par les brumes de mon
davidoff mêler aux effluves de la poire
williams rv volatiles recoins que je
m'entends dire que je m'entends dire que
à pabos la guerre est que ak qu'à la
mitrailleuse
aile cassée vilain takata kaboom
voyons ce mon petit pote enfin ce qui te
plaît dans l'aviation ces deux volets
mais pourquoi veux-tu à tout prix volet
dans l'armée c'est bien ce que ça
représente comores à venir un pilote de
chasse sais tu que ça peut tuer un
pilote de chasse et lui poliment surpris
en suisse
milliers
[Applaudissements]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
cette affaire est une carence qui
cette affaire sharansky qui a fait
pleurer dans les chaumières et sangloter
dans les kibboutz et bien émouvante et
puis n'avons nous pas lieu d'être fiers
nous autres français de vivre en ce pays
la france la france terre d'asile sans
goulag où les juifs court toujours
un ami publicitaires chez qui je prenais
impôts servent à 3 po bonjour les dégâts
s'étonnait que les soviétiques eu si
facilement laissé filer ce martyr vivant
de l'hydro totalitaire contre une
poignée de sous gestion en réalité plus
grillé que le feu rouge de la place
saint-michel les samedis soir de cuite
à la place de gorbatchev me disait cet
ami je n'aurais pas échanger et
sharansky contre de barils une lessive
ordinaire
on voit par là combien les gens de la
publicité on moralement et
intellectuellement évolué depuis l'ère
obscurantistes débats dimanche de la
brillantine cadeaux ricin et de la
dauphine renault dont d'intrépides
pionnier de la réclame sonore chantait
ainsi les louanges sur radio abidjan au
milieu des années 50
faites attention je vais chanter
mais pas longtemps vous n'aurez pas
longtemps je vous demande de rester les
coudes ce n'est qu'un mauvais moment à
passer le journal de patrice bertin et
juste après
alors pour push je vous épargne l'accent
ivoiriens y'a pas de raison que je
prenne l'accent il varie ivoiriens je
veux dire quand il chantait la
marseillaise rouget ne prenait pas
l'accent 2001
alors on va écouter la pub de la
dauphine radio abidjan pour promener yao
koffi et puis kouadio j'ai acheté une
drôle de petite auto au promener yao
confié puis kouadio j'ai acheté une auto
c'est une voie d'eau
merci je pense que cela méritait une
brève ovation
à vrai dire la plus grande victime de la
publicité contemporaine sur elle même et
sur l'image ringarde au mercantile qui
lui collait taux spot ou au placard
c'est selon le support ça plus génial et
ça plus subtile idées à la pub c'est
d'avoir réussi en quelques années à se
hisser dans l'opinion au rang d'un art à
part entière au rang d'un art nouveau le
huitième ou neuvième suivant que vous
mettiez ou non le cul dans le temps
désormais on débat dans les salons du
dernier clip pense à nouilles les
journaux bon chic bonne gauche analyse
minutieusement à longueur de colonnes
les allégories parra phrénique sous
jacente dans le message canigou on
s'entre décerne des trophées comme à
cannes et on ne dit plus qu on fait de
la pub on fait de la communication
d'ailleurs si jamais vous voyez le mot
publicité dans le nom d'une agence de
publicité je vous ai change sakharov
contre deux mistral gagnant
naguère méprisé par l'élite la publicité
à force de s'auto convaincre qu'elle
avait du génie a fini par en persuader
les autres y compris mon beau frère
christian daguerre encore publiphobe au
point qu'il allait en lambeaux à force
d'avoir tenté en vain de découdre les
crocodiles sur ses polos pour ne pas
avoir à participer au renom de monsieur
lacoste sur les courts de tennis ou
d'ailleurs son maintien crêpier de la
raquette
servait plus les intérêts de monsieur
tefal que ceux de ce grand joueur de
ping pong sur gaza pour être franc il
faut reconnaître que la pub ne les a pas
volés finalement ses lettres de noblesse
si l'on veut bien accepter les
crapuleries près paléolithique de
certains cuistre lessiviers évidemment
oui seuls quelques traits pas nation
bâclé à la tronçonneuse malpropre ou l'
intrusion inopinée d'un entrepôt pittet
quai d'une truie gonflables dans leur
arbre généalogique peuvent expliquer les
mystérieux mobile qui poussent parfois
des êtres humains extérieurement normaux
a tenté de faire vendre des poudre à
laver en montrant la femme comme une
soeur inférieure de la guenon
c'est même un handicapé moteur ça tourne
sitôt fini de filmer plein pot déconne
heureuse de frotter la merde se
regroupent temps des tavernes huppé ou
frétillant dans leurs blousons courrèges
le chivas à la main et la banane dans
l'oreille il distribue sans rire des
blâmes et des satisfecit aux derniers
films de kubrick ou d'ettore scola
mais il y a aussi les franches et good
chico bien l'as chatiliez ou beineix et
chabrol lassé d'un long métrage et plein
d'autres encore mais je connais mieux
les crus du médoc qui nous font chavirer
l'oeil de folimage éclaboussante qui
sont vraiment la beauté pure de cette
morne fin de siècle dont on ne voit
jamais la fin parce que tout le monde se
dégonfle d'appuyer sur le bouton pour
déclencher la troisième je le répète et
je pèse mes mots ce que font ces gens
ces publicitaires là c'est beau je vous
fais une confidence j'ai réussi à me
procurer la cassette de la superbe
publicité citroën les chevrons sauvages
de richard rénale est bien quand je me
sent déprimé je me la projette sur le
combiné et et les vidéos que j'ai fait
installer dans ma voiture une ford ont
fait pas plus confortable
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait que
c'est dur mais c'est ainsi j'ai beau
vivre travailler faire l'amour sortir
jouer avec et non pas sur des femmes je
continue de passer pour misogyne aux
yeux d'une minorité d'anciennes
combattante ou demeurant plus femelles
que féministe certes mais quand même ça
fait de la peine j'en connais une qui
est fermé aux joies simples de
l'hétérosexualité au point que quand on
lui dit bande elle pensa velpeau
cette femme d'autant plus déroutante
qu'elle ressemble plus à ornella mutti
qu'un chômeur haïtien voulu tant
d'autres temps brûlé brassens à propos
de son hommage à la vénus callipyge dont
voici quelques verres exquis
madame votre dos perd son nom avec si
bonne grâce qu'on ne peut s'empêcher de
lui donner raison
c'est le duc de bordeaux qui 120 est
basse car il ressemble au mien comme
deux gouttes d'eau s'il ressembler aux
vôtres on dirait quand il passe c'est un
joli garçon que ce duc de bordeaux
sans m'appesantir sur une évidence qui
veut que brassens était aussi anti
féministe que zola était antisémite
et pour en revenir à mon propos avant
que vous ne passiez sur europe 1 pour
écouter elkabbach
imaginez vous que la dame dont je brosse
est ci dessus un portrait succinct
certes mais malhonnête ma
téléphoniquement engueuler pour me
reprocher de n'être pas venue participer
le mois dernier un débat organisé par
l'association des femmes journalistes
sur le thème rabâcher mais toujours
actuel de la cruelle défection féminine
parmi les élus du peuple et dans les
instances dirigeantes des partis
et c'est un fait que les parties sont le
plus souvent entre les mains des hommes
et que les femmes
et que les femmes restent à la queue et
c'est dommage parce que bon
eh bien ma chère marielle dans l'élite
et elle se prénomme anne-sophie mais je
l'appelle marielle pour faire moins
gonzesses en vérité ma camarade c'est
par pure lâcheté que je n'ai pas honorer
l'aimable invitation de florence
montreynaud la présidente de la mjc
débat organisé au plm saint jacques à
paris ou par parenthèse les licencie
confortable qu'on petit partout et 3
percheronne d'un coup sans réveiller
l'émirat pétrole en veilleuse à côté
j'ai craint mes soeurs que vous ne me
juge acier importuns plutôt qu utile et
que vous ne me lyncher à 6 ou me kouyias
y est partout partout sauf au sax et bon
temps la piètre théorie que je vous
aurais soumises m'apparaissent est
susceptible d'exacerber votre courroux
en effet j'avais envie de vous suggérer
une hypothèse insoutenable vous autres
qui souhaitait bâtir un monde en jupon
armés selon laquelle l'une des causes de
la faible participation des femmes sur
la scène politique serait le simple
mépris qu elles en ont
s'il y a peu de femmes boxeur
boxeuse pardon budget s'il ya peu de
femmes boxeur ou colonel d'infanterie
c'est peut-être parce que la plupart
d'entre elles n'aiment pas prendre des
coups de poing sur la gueule
et s'il ya peu de femmes députées c'est
peut-être parce qu'elles ont mieux à
faire l'après midi que de participer au
désolant d'empoignade entre la rose fané
et le fumier qui la fit éclore
peut-être noms tels qu'indifférence ou
mépris pour tous et en palais bourbon
dans les hippo crétion subalternes
pousse parfois à l'honnête homme est
souvent le net femmes à se demander si
l'on ne devrait pas élevé l'absentéisme
électorale au rang de vertu civique
et ne venaient pas poulette me gonfler
les surrénales avec vos accusations de
paternalisme je ne suis pas paternaliste
je puis vous dire au moins trois femmes
très bien de mes amis avec de
l'intelligence et dessins partout qui
sont patronne de leurs affaires et de
leur vie et qu'ils préféreraient
renoncer au port du porte jarretelles
plutôt que d'entrer en politique
allez salut les qui à la vanille la
prochaine fois c'est juré c'est moi qui
vous invite au plm pour un 5 à 7 non
engagé je connais un jeu formidable
en plus c'est facile
c'est pas cher et moi ça me rapporte
rien quant au mois de mars je le dis
sans aucune arrière pensée politique ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
un critique de films dont je tairai le
nom afin qu'il n'émerge point du
légitime anonymat ou le maintien son
indigence
écrivait dans un hebdomadaire dans
lequel de crainte qu'il n'y pourrissent
je n'en fermerai pas mais aar en
un critique de films disais je donc
avant de m'en sablé dans les méandres
sournois de maigreur égaré entre 2,6
éloigné du début de phrase que volatile
pas que je sais puis le coin que je
cause
un critique de films écrivait récemment
à propos je crois d'une comédie de
claude zidi deux points ouvrez les
guillemets avec des pincettes
c'est un film qui n'a pas d'autre
prétention que celle de nous faire rire
je dis merci
merci à toi continent cre est
injustement ignorées merci d'avoir fait
sous toit permettant ainsi à l'humble
chroniqueur radiophonique quotidien de
trouver matière et je pèse mes mots à
entretenir sa verve misanthropique que
les yeux tendres des enfants et la
douceur de vivre en ce pays sans barroso
fenêtres des dictateurs en fuite font
encore trop souvent chanceler c'est la
verve qui gens c'est la cellule soyez
attentif quand même merci sinistre
issime ruminants pour l'irréel
perfection de tabous vous êtes allé
comme un engrais prometteur sur le pré
clairsemée de mon inspiration vacillante
où je cherchais en vain ce soir les
trèfles à quatre griefs de ma haine
ordinaire qui s'épanouit jour après jour
où vent mauvais qui l'est par pi sur
1850 de mettre grandes ondes avant la
publicité pour le gan élu abbé et le
journal de patrice bertin mais pour
écouter dans les tunnels essayez l'afm
relisons ensemble cette sentence digne
de figurer au fronton du mausolée à la
gloire du connard méconnu mort pour la
petite france
c'est un film qui n'a pas d'autre
prétention que celle de nous faire rire
d'abord je passerai sur l'écrasante
fadeur du lieu comme on a justement mis
le doigt récemment sur l'immense ennuis
distillé à longueur de discours par la
fameuse langue de bois des politiciens
et des politiques ont mais tirait donc
celle de certains si elle pas celle la
langue mais tirait donc celle de
certains journalistes et vous verrez
qu'elle est chargée on se perd en
conjectures sur les causes de l'accident
et au murmure dans les milieux
généralement bien informé qu'on laisse
entendre de source sûre mais devant
l'amas de tôles froissées de poutres
calcinées l'innocence victime ne fait
que répéter cet affreux cet affreux et
et gageons que cette soirée n'engendrera
pas la mélancolie
nous y revoilà
je sens qu'ils vont bien dormir au
sommet de la francophonie ici c'est
comme ça ce qui sans génie je vous la
corde me fait bouillir c'est qu'un
cuistre aux raz b c'est là que dis-je
l'art l'artisanat du rire au rang d'une
pâlotte besogne est pour façonneur
léthargique de cocottes en papier
attention qu'on me comprenne je ne
plaide pas pour ma chapelle d'ailleurs
je ne cherche pas à vous faire rire mais
seulement à nourrir ma famille en
abordant ici
chaque jour un grand problème
d'actualité ceci est une chronique qui
n'a pas d'autre prétention que celle de
me faire manger d'accord
mais toi qui es tu 0 flapi pour te
permettre de penser que le labeur du
clown se fait sans la sueur de l'homme
quitte autorise à croire que l'humoriste
et sans orgueil mais elle est immense
mon cher la prétention de faire rire un
film un livre une pièce un dessin qui
cherche à donner de la joie à vendre de
la joie faut pas déconner non plus ça se
prépare ça se découpent ça se polit une
oeuvre pour de rire ça se tourne comme
un fauteuil d'ébéniste ou comme un
compliment je ne sais pas si tu vois ce
que je veux dire avec ce trou béant dans
ta boîte crânienne
molière qui fait toujours rire le
troisième âge a transpiré à en mourir
chaplin a sué guitry s'est défoncé woody
allen et mel brooks se sont fatigués
souvent pour avoir eu 20 heures par jour
la prétention de nous faire rire claude
zidi s'emmerde et parfois se décourager
s'épuiser continue et c'est souvent
terribles car il arrive que ces films ne
fasse rire que lui et 2 charlott' sur
trois
mais tu ne m'ôtera pas de l'idée qu'il
faut plus d'ambition d'idées et de
travail pour accoucher des ripoux que
pour avorter des films foetus à la duras
et autres déliquescence placentaire ou
le cinéphile lacanien rejoint
l'handicapé mentale dans un même élan
d'idolâtrie pour tout ce qui ressemble
de près ou de loin à de la merde
pauvre petit censeurs de joie tu sais ce
qu'ils te dis monsieur hulot quant au
mois de mars je le dis sans aucune
arrière pensée politique ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Musique]
ma vie n'est pas ce sont les membres yb
lequel la mouette sk gas l'un des plus
beaux palaces hôtel de genève
un grand beau cube adouci aux
entournures cachant aux yeux du
populaire sous sa brillante carapace de
verres fumés des chambres de princesses
et des salons des bennes où seul le
cliquetis assourdi d'une cuillère
d'argent sur un cristal de dôme où le
froissement craquelé d'un billet de 100
dollars viennent parfois troublé à peine
le silence feutré des moquettes vers
tente si profonde que les plus petits
émir chatouiller sous les bras par le
redoux poil de l'aisne épurer les
parcours tant pouffant d'un beau rire
orientale
j-20 dormir trois nuits au frais de mon
éditeur lequel ébloui par le chiffre de
mes tirages au seuil de l'année nouvelle
m'avait envoyé ronronner là pour que je
me partage as entre deux interviews
qu'on passait par 6 et 2 intervieweuse
qu'on passait par là
avec des gros lots pour la partie
ludique
au soir du troisième jour alors que
l'hôtel était bondé du nord de gominés
de parvenus de style vuitton cartier
atterries en ces lieux pour assister à
je ne sais plus quel salon de la
décoration de bureau pour amateurs
d'ordinateurs louis 15 voici qu'apparaît
est à la réception et à l'improviste un
magnifique ministre princier d'un état
du golfe avec une noble tête de pirates
du désert sur un ensemble balmain pied
de poule et à gori élastiquée camionnage
beau comme un depardieu rectifie au brou
de noix
cher réceptionniste dit le ministre ou
tara les biens à leur famille à hawaii
tamagna ou à talla tine
plait-il s'étonna la réceptionniste
well i l'armoire d'app line say that i
would like to get de room one hundred un
ultimate
le réceptionniste hélas du s'aplanir en
excuses navré la suite 138 celle que le
prince et son rookie des sables habite
est habituellement était
exceptionnellement occuper son altesse
aurait dû réserver mais il restait une
chambre simple la 147 or le ministre
exigeait que son garde du corps dormi
dans la même suite que lui sur un lit de
camp dans la pièce contiguë hélas ou là
ou là cette nuit là non seulement il ne
restait qu'une chambre mais tous les
lits de camp avaient été réquisitionnés
pour les épouses et les états ire des
cadres brillantine et suse décrit son
altesse acceptera-t-elle
exceptionnellement que son collaborateur
dormi à l'étagé du dessus ou restait une
chambrette mansardé sous le toit yara
admettait cure là le ministre ce qu'on
peut traduire en substance par [ __ ] de
bordel de merde chienne de vie
le réceptionniste affolé réveilla le
directeur le prince était le meilleur
client de l'hôtel l'été ils venaient
prendre les eaux du lac avec son harem
les cousines de son harem les soeurs des
cousines de soirée m et des tas de potes
sous zémire pétrolifères djellabi qu qui
venait déverser leurs milliards
superflue par les fenêtres du casino la
seule exigence de ce client en or
étaient confie dormir sont musclés près
de lui
je suis infiniment confus dit le
directeur je ne vois qu'une solution ce
serait que monsieur ajoute-t-il en
montrant la bête humaine veuille bien
couché dans le lit de votre altesse dans
le lit même de votre altesse dans la
chambre 147 je ferai remarquer à votre
altesse qu'il s'agit d'un lit de 250 cm
de large ce qui exclut toute toute
éventualité de promiscuité
désobligeantes n'est ce pas ajouta-t-il
avec un accent vaudois approximatif car
il était de berne
ya à leur aide betek rural à la
seigneurie signifiant qu'il n'était
absolument pas question qu'un prince de
sang s'allonge à jamais dans les mêmes
draps carte huriez du même sexe
finalement c'est une petite soubrette
espagnol qui trouva la solution
elle suggéra timidement commis trois
bras dans le lit le prince dormirai
entre le premier et le deuxième bras le
gorille entre le deuxième et le
troisième drame on l'applaudît ont fuit
comme elle l'avait dit tout le monde
hormis bien cette nuit là le prince
n'est pas à pas la soubrette mais il lui
fit porter des fleurs tout à fait
merveilleuse qui la firent s'émouvoir de
ravissement
cette fable bien sûr ne vaut que parce
qu'elle n'en est pas une elle est
authentique et rassurante dans la mesure
où elle nous prouve qu'on a souvent
besoin d'un plus petit que soi pour
réussir le clivage des classes sociales
dans les contes à dormir coucher
quant au mois de mars y apprend la
bretèque je le dis sans aucune arrière
pensée politique ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
passent l'hiver
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet je
rêve aussi avec moi aussi j'ai vu les
césars c'était très très bien et tout
cette vraie sincérité qui éclatent sur
les visages de tous ces gens qui sont
très très malheureux de pas pouvoir
partager leurs cadeaux avec les
ouvreuses et les machinistes vraiment
bouleversée et je tenais ont profité
pour dire je remercie beaucoup france
inter sans qui je serai sur europe 1
je voudrais remercier ses micros sans
lequel ma voix ne toucherait pas
barbizon je voudrais remercier rika
zaraï leprince ringuet pas devenu et
puis finalement je voudrais aussi
remercier mon cul devoir supporter mes
jambes jusqu'à vous ce soir j'ai une
enfant doué d'un tempérament très
original elle regarde récré a2 elle a
des bisounours elle aime le chocolat au
lait et elle collectionne les
autocollants
elle passe le plus clair de ses loisirs
à mangs lui et de tendresse afin que je
fasse jouer mes relations dans les
milieux des calicots pour lui obtenir à
n'importe quel prix n'importe quelle
sorte de vignettes pourvu qu'elles
soient adhérentes sur tous supports y
compris sur le chat qui bien que noir de
poils et persan d'origine pour ne pas
dire arabes se promener hier encore avec
un dossard proclamant son soutien à jean
marie le pen
samedi matin comme cette petite personne
rentrait de l'école avec rtl sur le pull
et europe 1 entre les oreilles quelle
honte je lui signifiait sévèrement ma
réprobation pour cet engouement
cocardier quand le téléphone fixe quoi
sauna c'était joëlle kauffmann la femme
de jean paul je devrais dire la femme
sans jean paul carrel ne vibre ne bouge
ne se désole ne se démène qu'au fond du
trou sans fin de cette absence
intolérable qui lui mangent la vie elle
me demandait de venir éventuellement
l'après midi même sur la péniche amarrée
soul pour neuf où est installé le comité
de soutien jean paul kauffmann et aux
autres otages elle donnerait une
conférence de presse à 16h pour
souligner le début du dixième mois de
détention de son mari et de michel
seurat du 12e mois pour fontaine et
cartons en règle générale je ne
manifeste jamais mes sentiments mes
idéaux mais combat en public sauf quand
c'est payé
j'ai mes pauvres j'aimais déshérités
j'ai des opinions mais je m'interdis le
plus souvent de les exhiber en public
persuadé qu'il ya toujours une certaine
impudeur a montré son coeur à tous les
passants pour pas un rond alors qu'on se
fait rétribuer pour leur montrer
justement son cul
et puis je suis bien trop maladivement
individualiste pour manifester à plus de
mais là je ne sais pas pourquoi je ne
résiste pas à joëlle kauffmann elle me
bouleverse à force de ne jamais
s'effondrer elle elle va faire libérer
son bonhomme parce que neuf mois ça
suffit comme ça faut pas pousser allons
allons ouvrait moi cette porte est
brisée mois ses barreaux joëlle
kauffmann me fait un peu penser à une
autre femme que je connais qui a un
cancer et qui va guérir parce que moi
vous comprenez la mort ça va comme ça
j'ai quand même pas que ça à faire
une question cependant ne hantait charge
aux ailes est-ce que vous distribuez des
autocollants sur votre péniche
elle me dit que oui
j'allais donc à sa conférence de presse
il faisait un froid bleus sur paris et
sur la scène de ces vents qui pince et
bleuissent et foule au pied les espoirs
de monsieur thermolactyl
joël nous a fait du vin chaud avec de la
cannelle
il y avait là tassés comme des oiseaux
frileux dans le nid de ce bateau ventru
des journalistes aussi bronzée qu
célèbre un architecte émouvant un avocat
humain
d'autres journalistes pas les moins
connus et puis cette poignée de jeunes
gens incroyables et bénévoles qui se
shootent à l'espoir quand d'autres se
fixe à l'héroïne
joël est monté sur le pont pour lire son
communiqué à la presse
elle est là la halle nez rougi par la bi
lisez les yeux pétillants sombre
farouche du désir d'en finir avec ce
calvaire inhumain gencher d'inquiétude
mortels et du désert de lui pendant que
les gens d'antenne 2 montrent leur
caméra baladeuse afin de l'enregistrer
elle me prend par le bras et se met à
rire en me montrant le port neuf elle me
raconte que quand kristo a emballé les
ouvrages il s'est montré un peu ennuyé
de la promiscuité forcée de son oeuvre
avec cette péniche placardés de photos
des otages vous comprenez madame nous
faisons la fête de la joie vous
comprenez et vous vous ne vous nous
montrez du drame alors ça va pas
tellement bien c'est un peu fâcheux vous
pourriez peut-être aller plus loin avec
votre péniche
oui c'est parfaitement authentique dit
je signale gueule la plupart même tous
les médias étaient au courant de cette
anecdote et qu'aucun n'a jamais soufflé
mot parce qu'en france terre de coire
est faux culs les mêmes qui se pâment
devant guernica vous feront remarquer
qu'on ne mélange pas l'art et la douleur
dans la même rubrique
aux cris de libérez kaufmann et
lebourgneuf les amis de joël ont fait
revenir cristaux sur ses aspirations
séparatistes
finalement joël maintenant et sur le pot
c'est plus qu'une image c'est une figure
de proue
elle lit d'une voix forte et décider
22 février 86 9 mois de détention pour
jean paul kauffmann et michel seurat 11
mois pour marcel carton et marcel
fontaine que signifie pour nous de
marquer à nouveau la date mensuel de
cette cruelle détention qui ne trouve
pas d'issue au delà de ma propre douleur
je renouvelle pour mes enfants et ma
famille un appel désespéré à tout homme
de bonne volonté ici ou ailleurs en
france et en europe en afrique et au
moyen-orient pour contribuer à la
libération immédiate de jean paul et de
ses compagnons de détention que ceux qui
se battent à cet instant même pour que
s'ouvre la porte de leurs jeunes
puissent enfin réussir fin de citation
fin du jour fin du vin chaud ce soir
lundi et le 275e jours après le premier
jour où la vie des kaufmann s'est mise
entre les parenthèses d'acier de la
folie des hommes moi je m'en fous j'ai
mon auto collants et depuis ce matin sur
le cahier d'écolier ou eluard
écrivait-on nom et où j'écris cette
chronique
j'ai mis près du tien liberté le nom de
kaufman
tantôt mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière-pensée pas
m'étendre
bonjour
[Musique]
c'est non